oh man oh this is not gonna be easy as I
thought it was an outdoorsy person so
sometimes living in New York City can
feel constraining friends started
sending me articles about a guy from New
Jersey who actually kayaks to work so
when I heard about a company that made a
collapsible kayak to fit in my closet I
decided I had to try this out but first
I had to talk to him
how did this happen kind of uneventful
'hey buddy that i used to work with and
I were working long hours and taking the
bus typically back out of Port Authority
at you know 12:00 1:00 to 3:00 o'clock
in the morning and thinking about better
ways to get to and from the city if we
were both living over in Hoboken kayak
seemed like a great idea we had him on
the Jersey side and then kayak across
really early one morning and had you
know no idea about you know which
directions the current going is sort of
like let's just get to the other side
and how quickly can you cross it's about
15 minutes in the water what should I
know what should I be worried about
bring a bottle of water and I always
have the lifejacket on Zach lives in New
Jersey and travels to Manhattan via the
Hudson River I live in Queens so I'm
gonna have to travel to work via Big
East River
[Music]
I live just a few blocks from here and
this is the nearest kayak launch but the
waters pretty clear my die this video
still gets edited okay so it is right
now 8:30 I have a 10 o'clock meeting at
work so I left myself about an hour and
a half to be able to get there in time
and then walk the distance from 14th
streets rest of the way I had a bow in
ten minutes to be able to put this
together alright so now it's about 8:45
I should probably be able to get there
in the next hour and then heading to
work and so bad there's no boats
anywhere water's pretty clear and you
know what I'm actually going pretty
quickly it's much calmer than I thought
would be I really expect this to be a
real rolling River oh man oh
all right so I just got like flipped
around by the current man I am flying
now in the opposite direction this is
not going to be easy as I thought it was
and see for the child's again I was
reading that the current would be
pushing me south I'm going I mean push
the other way all right you see that you
don't see the current there and it
really is is crazy going towards it
really quickly really quickly and let's
see what happens when I hit it I mean
it's good to me right around and not a
shot I'm a shot at that all right this
is third attempt I'm gonna give it
everything I have
[Music]
[Music]
right back to where I started I think
the guys that are riding their kayaks
work they're not going down river they
must just be crossing because like I'm
right now within a short distance of and
I can probably cross you issue
alright well do you wanna be late for
work
[Music]